let's bring in Rick Sutcliffe ESPN
baseball analyst on course former sy
Young Award winner hey son how are you
this morning
I'm doing great Danno I will admit it
it's kind of early here in San Diego but
to be with you
I got in a lot of trouble the last time
I was on with you I guess I started
rambling and telling some stories and
stuff so we'll try to stay away from
that this morning wait which specific
story got you in trouble I don't know I
got several calls people thought they
were kind of funny you know that the
funny part about it was really the
funniest thing that you asked me a
question like what's happened lately the
funniest thing that happened the last
month of the season you know we've been
working with David Ross at ESPN in the
last couple of years and Buch Jambi and
I did some games there in September well
we go into extra innings in Boston and
David I don't know if this is norm or
what but he he went to the bathroom like
for the fourth time well he gets up and
you know at times sometimes there's a
quick inning when he comes back in then
you can picture this he sets down real
quiet because we're on the air and as he
sets down he puts the headset on I
looked at John Giambi and I go I had him
stop I go John that's a great point I go
David what do you think and he had no
idea what you guys are talking about on
camera of course you got to get a
producer he turns bright red and this
was great he goes I don't know what
you're talking about
I was in the bathroom he goes we start
laughing he goes I didn't know I was
working with two camels they were mad
about I should have shared that but I as
usual I drew a blank on that story so
what did you expect to happen in this
world series nothing different
Daniel than what we saw all year long
you know the Boston Red Sox dominated
the regular season we saw what they did
in New York I think probably the most
impressive thing was how they went to
New York in the division series and won
two games there they celebrated at
Yankee Stadium they go to the World
Series the reigning World Series
champion the Astros and
they go three you know down in Houston
of course they're celebrating out on
their field and then you just you just
even though things didn't go right in
Game three when they lost in 18 innings
you just you had the feeling you just
knew when you saw some of the interviews
you saw some of the things that went on
with the club they didn't take it as a
loss they they looked at that as a
positive with the way some guys stood up
Nathan Eovaldi I mean come on now I mean
a lot of people might not have even
known his name
you knew he's out of baseball a couple
of Tommy John's I think you and I both
agreed that I'd like to have him on my
team
anytime anywhere and I also think when
you look at the World Series a lot of
times we focus on the negative right
after the World Series
we should celebrate what the Red Sox did
but it feels like Dave Roberts is going
to be under the microscope for a little
while what kind of thoughts questions
did you have with how he handled his his
pitching staff you know I think I really
had more questions about the handling of
the staff last year in the World Series
and I did this year the the one big
question Dan that I had that that I
didn't understand was in Game four he
brings kenley jansen in to pitch the
eighth inning and I might be missing
something here because I did not do the
series I watched this of course there
you know when you're watching that
you're at a party and there's a lot
going on but what I didn't understand he
brings Janssen in with a four to three
lead in the eighth inning he gives up
the home run to Steve Parris okay it's
tied well if it the score was four to
three you're gonna run him back out
there in the ninth inning
that was your plan I guess was to pitch
him in the eighth and ninth
well you didn't pinch-hit for him I mean
he stood he only threw ten pitches my
biggest question for Dave Roberts if I
would have been in the in the meeting
managers meetings yesterday was why okay
it's tied four to four and then we know
that that every manager in baseball when
you're tied at home you put your closer
in for the top of the ninth to give
yourself a chance to win it in the
bottom of the night with him only
throwing ten pitches in the eighth
inning my question would have been why
didn't why didn't you send me back out
there for the ninth why am I seeing
Dylan floral out there in Game four
after you just won Game three yeah I
would have sent Janssen back out there
to try to win that ballgame and even the
series up
that was the biggest surprise to me
that's the one that kind of just jumped
out it mean I might have been missing
some I know they pinched it for Barnes
III I don't think there was any move
made that that made Janssen unavailable
that would have been the big question
that I had when it comes to dynasties it
feels like it depends on the sport you
know the Golden State Warriors are a
dynasty the Patriots are a dynasty when
it comes to baseball you know are the
Red Sox a dynasty when you consider that
you don't really have a common thread as
far as manager or star player with
what's happened to this franchise but
when you think of dominating or baseball
you know why's that they're dominating
franchise is this a dynasty yes yes
without a doubt in my mind you know it's
kind of a New England thing I mean when
you think about it if they don't play in
the World Series and play in a Super
Bowl it's kind of been a difficult year
for them but I'll tell you something
then that I learned the earlier last
year from the president of the Red Sox
Sam Kennedy Sam talked about there being
a difference between spending and
investing when when you look at what
they've done yeah they brought in a
young manager in Alex Cora who you can't
say enough good things about him and I'm
sure you have all year long but what did
they do for Alex Cora that they brought
in Ron Roenicke a guy who was you know
with the Angels in 2002 with Mike
Scioscia he managed in Milwaukee I don't
think there's a better bench coach
third-base coach and all a baseball than
Ron Roenicke so you don't bring in a
rookie manager and not supporting with
somebody that you know is going to have
this back in every situation the one the
one thing that stands out at me about
Alex core the first month of the season
was he and in a ninth-inning with a
one-run lead he didn't put Jackie
Bradley jr. in center and take JD
Martinez out of the game and after the
game it didn't have anything to do with
the outcome they want but after the game
the Boston media was like hey why didn't
you make that move and then you know I
mean but a lot of people out there might
not know Alex Kerr said I didn't think
of it you know what the media's ready to
pounce honey
and after him saying that you can't do
that now listen to this and Ronnie's
gonna be mad at me but a month later I
asked Ron Roenicke I go hey how come you
guys didn't do that and he goes I go I
love what Alex Cora said that I didn't
think of he goes well suck that's not
exactly the truth I go what's the truth
he goes he kind of did that just to
deflect the media he goes we talked
about putting Jackie Bradley in there
and he asked me what I would do and I
said I wouldn't do it because JD
Martinez the spot comes up fourth in the
bottom of the ninth if they tie it we're
gonna lose his bat and Alex goes okay
let's leave him in there then so he you
know it's that personality it's that
ability to communicate not only in the
clubhouse but with the media with the
public we know the one thing he did when
he signed his contract he called Sam
Kennedy Tom Warner and and John Henry
back he said I need one more thing what
they're going like okay he needs another
year and he's more money what what is it
he goes I need a Plane full of goods to
go to my country in Puerto Rico I want
to be on that I want to go down there
and help help help help Puerto Rico and
they just like lit up and that last
thing I heard I think they sent four or
five planes down there to help so that
that tells you a lot about the human
being that the Boston Red Sox hired
he's Rick Sutcliffe the ESPN baseball
analyst joining a stand Patrick show
more likely to be in a Dodger uniform
next season Manny Machado or Clayton
Kershaw ocher sure I'll be there and I
don't think at this point in his career
with all the back injuries that he's
left I don't know that there's anybody
out there that's gonna pay him more or
add more years to the contract that he's
already on you know no no doubt in my
mind
Kenny Machado that's it that's a
different situation I mean you know a
couple of things that went on in the
playoffs and a couple of things that
were said I don't know if it's gonna
cost you more money or not we've seen
owners go crazy on contracts when he got
a chance to add a talent like him I like
Manny Machado a lot but you know with
what he did by going by there and
kicking the ankles what he did in the
Milwaukee series some of that stuff is
you know when when an ownership asked
their key players you want do you want
to add that to your team or not I think
there's going to be some guys that
little hesitant about that so no doubt
in my mind the Kershaw and I could been
wrong many times but the Clayton Kershaw
will continue to end his career in the
Dodger uniform Scott Boras on his side
topic says that he's already got an
offer and it's already wrapped up even
though it's not official with Bryce
Harper a do you believe that and B if
you do
where is Bryce Harper going to be next
season I would believe that he has an
offer I wouldn't believe that it's
wrapped up
I mean Bryce you know he's earned the
right by by playing this out and and
going by the rules to become a free
agent you got to take a look at it I
mean he's got to take a look at it
what's out there I mean I think back to
Dallas Green wanted to meet with me in
1980 for the last month of the season
and after you know winning ten or
whatever whatever after getting hot he
says you don't really need to meet right
now you've earned the right to get out
there and look I think Bryce Harper
would would be silly to to have things
already wrapped up without seeing what
else is out there and you know the
priority for him right now it has got to
be finding a team that he can win the
World Series on who would you rather
have
Bryce Harper Manny Machado I'd rather
have Bryce I'd rather have right and you
know what I would have said Machado
before the postseason started now but
I'm not gonna be Johnny hustle I'm not
gonna run things out that that's just
not the tone that I would want to set
for an organization and that's not the
way Bryce Harper plays the game you're
pretty sharp at 6:30 in the morning are
you still up from last night no I'm not
you know that you know I tried you know
partying with Bill Murray one time and
and then I went on the air that night
that as you know didn't work out real
well I did lad hey I want to share one
thing with you - what one thing that I
really thought was the key to the Boston
Red Sox this year they hired away the
assistant hitting coach from a year ago
from the Dodgers Tim hires Tim hires
told me I said how did you guys put it
together offensively last year he goes
we started something along with the
hitting coach turn award called hitters
meetings and Dan oh it's a lot like what
you and the Dan dance to do every
morning you guys talk about who the
guests are what the question should be
I know you include your staff a lot as
everybody should this was the key Tim
hires told me something that the Dodgers
were trying to hide in the hitters
meetings what they did there was they
included Justin Turner and Justin Turner
would speak he would go out and apply it
and as Dave Roberts told me you know
once it's out in the universe you own it
you got to go out there and apply that
well all of a sudden all the Dodgers bit
in on that well when hires came over to
Boston he got JD Martinez to buy in on
it because they know if you're not the
one leading the show and you don't
encourage everybody in your in your
office to say something then they're not
gonna say anything well when all of a
sudden JD Martinez is telling Mookie
Betts hey what are you gonna do off this
guy well to begin with Mookie was like
well I'm just gonna see it and hit it
well that's not enough what what are you
gonna do what are you looking for I tell
you what these hitters meetings that the
Dodgers came up with last year and the
Red Sox applied this year I think's a
huge key to the reason those were the
last two teams standing in baseball this
year refresh our memory how banged up
were you after you went out with Bill
Murray I didn't I didn't feel banged up
at all that fact I don't know that I
ever felt better when did you know you
were in trouble when you were on the air
you know what I didn't know it at all I
didn't even realize they had pulled the
plug on me I didn't know that it was so
funny so he spends the night with me
right and we drive to his course there's
about an hour away from San Diego Palma
Valley we grew up there and I never
turned my phone on we played we played
all day we're sitting there having lunch
and all of a sudden I turned my cell
phone on and then smoke was coming out
of that thing I'm going to boy well I
had a text message and I'm asking
everybody out there if you had a message
from your wife to call her or your agent
Barry Axelrod who you know ASAP
I mean who your agent call well my first
thought was something that happened my
grandpa because you know I was raised by
him and when Barry told me that you know
what's going on out there I thought oh I
lost my grandpa he goes I said his
grandpa okay he goes yeah he's fine he
goes but you're all over the world and I
go I go for what I didn't I don't know
that that point I even knew that I'd
gone on the air but you
turned out kind of great you know you
know Norby williamson better than I do
yeah Norby was great I had to call him
and he goes um you know we've been
trying to get ahold of you and I said I
know I'm sorry he goes if you ever do
that again and don't call me he says
you're in trouble and I got a little
upset like what do you mean well I mean
I what were you talking to that's what
he was talking about was if you ever
play golf with Bill Murray again and you
don't call me I got a week off which you
know it was kind of embarrassing but
we're back at it now
good to talk to you again bud thank you
hopefully I'll see you in spring
training that's Rick Sutcliffe yeah and
you think such funny or entertaining
here boy if you're out you're having a
couple of beverages he is he's the Pied
Piper he's got a million stories million
stories for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]